hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play charge
now you guys told me that there was an
ending to this game which I need to find
because this is actually a pretty
creative game and I like playing it so
here we go if I remember yes remember to
whatever Dibby Dibby Dibby okay so we're
charging down the hallways looking for
methods at which to reinvigorate our own
heart in case you didn't know like this
and grabbing on to these people and
zooming past them and that was Owney ng
which I create I corrected myself pretty
soon afterwards Han I got a good phone
yeah there we go okay
stamina I need a lot more charge I just
like a lot more charge where are all the
cops when you need them never around
okay here we go
doing good doing better I just got to
find my way and avoid all of the giant
of ambulances that somehow go down the
hall okay but so far so good
I'm not sure what would be at the end of
this game I mean it just seems like a
runner I mean this could this could be a
great like phone game that um requires
like you know just simple touch
interface and has a high score system it
would actually probably be pretty fun I
imagine it might actually sell well on
the on the App Store so if anyone wants
to give it a try well not anyone this
guy wants to get his try they could
definitely make a quick buck off it most
likely it's made on the Uni engine which
can be bad I live out my way I didn't
know if that thing killed me okay I need
um and you had to actually go into one
of these rooms
cuz I'm there we go that's what I needed
the big charger oh damn oh I did
hi thank you I need another area thank
you
all right so now that I've got that I
need to I need to go into the rooms more
but I'm just kind of in a hurry to get
to the end I mean the phones are okay
but they don't do very much at all down
that way don't give by that they're
taking out nurses left and right I feel
bad computer computer computer computer
keep the heart up ah
Pass uh-huh uh-huh
oh [ __ ] there's not one in here another
one
Oh piss there's no one in here
[ __ ] oh no oh no oh man I was just a
frickin massacre oh god I'm gonna my
heart's gonna stop
give me a charge buddy God that where
are they there's not one in here okay
seems like the cop tasers are enough can
I get on the right oh come on who the
Freak got in my way your sons of [ __ ]
all right fudge man this game actually
is quite fun so if you haven't tried it
already try it now the link is in the
description you can sit just a quick
download and pretty easy it's on the MVP
engine so no need to install just plug
and play let's go buddy
damn these comp [ __ ] I mean they
give me a charge but then they get that
friggin my way come on come on boost
boost boost me boo sweet moves me they
don't hear nothing really whistle
it's a hospital it's so very strange I'm
not sure I understand what the point is
to all of this nonsense nothing in there
give you boast I mean there must be some
greater purpose like I made a comparison
in the last time I play this to the
movie crank so there's got to be some
sort of analogy going on there
give me give me give me give me thank
you come on loose loose get to that room
there we go
still no charging play I need one watch
come on come on come on come on you
come here I kill you what do I kill the
guy when I get his taser what happens he
just falls over em away die important
business damn it this is no more
charging plates dad Amano don't take
them out I need them I need them I go I
need AB stop it you trolley bastards
gurney gurney bastards gimme gimme gimme
thank you thank you thank you thank you
oh thank you gimme gimme ultra super
mega combo action here gimme gimme gimme
gimme
okay keep going I must be getting
somewhere near I don't know how long
this game is but if you guys were just
trolling me and said that there was an
ending just to get me to play it again I
would be very upset but I'm doing pretty
good so long as I don't get hit by any
stray vehicles that are barreling down
the hallways I should be fine the
policemen seem to be able to keep me up
just fine so I don't know if I'll
actually need to find going to the rooms
except when I'm hiding from something
shoot up piss and away theaters
Computers Computers Computers going on
son alone that's another one hahaha
can't get me too smart for ha why did oh
[ __ ]
god dammit man piss your screw your
stuff you son of a [ __ ] what is that
ah that's bull puzzle at all whatever
alright let's go come on we got time or
we don't have time we got to get places
we got to go man gotta go man I gotta go
get on my way coppers you can't stop me
Jew prayer obviously not very Pro
because I keep getting murdered by these
guys
stupid hambulance is what are they doing
they're killing more people than they're
saving in their rush to get to wherever
they're going
oh come on come on come on all night
ha ha what are in those double doors
I've seen the nurses come out but I
don't think I've ever been in one I
should probably check it out next time I
assume by whoa that cop popped out of
nowhere come on come on come on gimme
okay
yeah I don't know why farther down the
hallway the electrical systems get a
little more Spartan but that's just the
way the hospital okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna check this okay I can't go in
there so never mind never mind a lot of
I but I cannot okay no ambulances please
no ambulances no whammies no whammies no
whammies ah give me
thank you now we go got to give it ample
time to not screw me over well come on I
need a charge where's a cop when you
need him cops thank you
I'm gonna go in here I'm gonna go in
here Oh Oh sounds like oh oh get out of
the way
brick where's the charge I need a charge
I need a charge man cop come here come
here
thank you that's close
Jesus man I gotta be getting close to
the end now I'll pass cowboy damn oh I
get all mine
Thank You Claire ha ha
clear I get it cuz never come on come on
come here come on
yes go back come on capita tired give me
the cop even the cops oh well they must
be running out after I murder you know
Oh
gotta get there gotta get there [ __ ] ah
damn I was close I don't even know if
you can go backwards so if I don't
manage to get it I probably be screwed
chimera gotta zoom top cop cop we ah man
I gotta be I said what's it end whoo ahh
Oh what wait what wait how do I get in
this is obviously my body and I'm a
ghost how do I do this what am i God put
out no don't
was that the end did I do it
did I do it or not did I get it I don't
know if I got it did I get it how do I
know if I got it how do I know nothing
happened
there was no ending I did I probably
[ __ ] something up I probably did god
damn it I did didn't I I did God what
did I do wrong
there was nothing to do there's nothing
to click on there was nothing to go for
maybe there was something like off to
the side maybe or I don't know maybe I
like needed to build up enough charge
just to be able to just to be able to
zap my body into life or maybe that was
just it was a morbid reality of death
even after all of my struggle and rush
to get to my destination I still wasn't
able to save myself or something it also
makes more sense that there wouldn't be
ambulances barreling down the hallway
and I am just some at the real operation
of someone's subconscious but at the
same time that's such bull is search
bird come on let's go let's go I got
places to be
I got a dead body to see go my good eye
hello thank you man that ambulance
really clears out the entire hallway I
will be boned oh come on
the sons of [ __ ] Louie that's a good
church I did not know about Alan
doc come here you nurses now go damn it
I'm gonna get hit by one of the Gurney's
and I'm not even pay attention because I
don't watch out for that threat okay so
I'm not even sure if I did something
wrong I don't know there was like no
confirmation ergo what could I have
possibly done I don't know I did I just
don't know it was not clear there was an
ending I don't think I got it but I'm
not sure just not sure I was too close
don't do that again
ah there's nothing actually in this room
oh come on I need something gimme
gimme-gimme-gimme fawn fawn fawn five
five five Oh another one
get on the romm son of a [ __ ] I'm gonna
die you [ __ ] a-hole
give me the phone oh not another one
you're kidding me is it ball
[ __ ]
god damn it did I get to the end was
that it was it was it I think maybe oh
did I get to the end I don't know how am
I supposed to know nothing happened
maybe that was it maybe I'll just end it
on that note the sad inevitability of
death is inescapable no matter how fast
you run or Never
no matter how hard you try there is no
running away from your own death so I
think I got the end if I didn't or if
there was some like button off to the
side that I was supposed to press I
don't know god damn okay I think that
was the end I'm not sure there was just
no confirmation for it so
kind of aggravating if I didn't don't
tell me
do not tell me if I die hope I did so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video
but
Oh
you